Jaakko my leader is not an extreme
ownership disciple among other things
he's fostering division within our team
how do I help lead those who no longer
trust in the commander but are awesome
guys who want to stay involved how do I
bring them back into the fold without
threatening our lead or our Dear Leader
alright well first of all you got to
become a buffer between your boss and
your team that's what you need to do try
and absorb as much negativity as you can
and make sure you don't spread that
negativity mm-hmm right this and also
this is a delicate situation that we've
talked about before if you completely
support the boss and and and act like
the boss is the greatest person in the
world the team is gonna reject you or
there's a like a high likelihood that
they're gonna reject you at the same
time if you completely reject the boss
then you've actually aided in dividing
the team hmm because now the team isn't
not aligned with the boss so you have to
balance you have to balance and one of
the best ways to do this is to put
listen this you gotta put the importance
of the mission and the team above the
egos and attitudes so here's I'm gonna
say something like look guys look guys I
know we have our differences with the
chain of command on some things but we
have a job to do alright we have a
mission to accomplish and even though we
might not agree with the boss on
everything it's our team it's our team
and the performance of the team sure it
reflects the boss but it reflects us too
so what I say we do is win let's let's
win let's be the best regardless of what
the boss does or what the boss says
let's win to prove to prove that even
with a situation where the leadership
might be lacking a bit we're so good
that we're gonna win anyways
who wants to get some of that right
there you go
let's win despite poor leadership that's
what we're gonna do anything I'll tell
you what in my younger and maybe a
little less politically savvy days I
would have said something like let's win
not just despite our leadership but
let's win to spite our leadership like
we would just perform so well in the
face of a horrible leader we're gonna
show everyone what was up the underdog
cinderella story we're gonna rock so
that's cool you know sometimes you're
you're winning
not just despite your leadership but to
spite them I've done that a couple times
in your career not not the bed of not
the best one it's better to win despite
them so despite we had some rough
leadership it's okay and the other thing
is you know you even when you're doing
that with a bad leader you still got to
be careful I've stepped on the leaders
toes and the way you do that is really
easy you give them all the credit you
give them all the credit and that's
great and that little nagging voice that
you've got in the back your head that
wants credit you know that what I'm
talking about that you go back there
don't worry about that I'm telling you
right now you will get the credit in the
long run you will get the credit don't
worry about it you might not get the
credit on this one or even this week
this month maybe not even this year but
eventually you will get the credit and
recognition that you deserve that you
want because your boss's boss he knows
what's up he knows what's up and your
troops know what's up
and so when everybody knows what's up
when you have a truly bad leader the
truly bad leader doesn't they're not
they're not just walking around fooling
everyone in an organization it's not
happening it's not happening and if it
does happen it doesn't happen for long
it only happens there's a limited time
that it can happen for because every
every idiotic move that that leader
makes down the chain of command at least
one out of every five he does some
stupid up the chain of command too and
so how is that group perform
so well we know it's not the leader he's
in he's an idiot oh they must have some
good junior leadership in there who's
those guys oh that's echo Charles he's
in charge of that squad and they're
crushing it so don't worry about that
just lead and win and give that credit
away and it's gonna come back to you
tenfold that's what you do and in a way
goes back to like people are watching
they're watching we're gonna pick up on
that yeah and they're not gonna you know
that doesn't mean that the boss's boss
is gonna advertise that is the boss the
boss they're a good leader yes oh the
boss is Boston you become and undermine
them yeah no but when the time comes for
emotion when the time comes for a
reorganization that's who's gonna be
happy you know that's where the that's
what the adjustments are gonna be made
yeah but we get so wrapped up we get the
ego gets yeah yeah ego gets you yeah
kind of watch hope for that thing yeah
to truly let it go when you don't get
the credit you for real think that you
deserve the credit to truly let it go
there's the challenge yeah that's a
challenging one relish in that challenge
laugh at it yeah you know good boss you
did awesome good job yeah cuz I thought
well I feel like anyway when that does
happen you know when something and it's
not even necessarily someone else gets
the credit for what you did it's just
that you like something big happen and
it just went completely unnoticed that
that it was straight-up because of you
right that's a potential scenario but
let's say you don't say anything I think
that there is a small feeling of
satisfaction that you're like you know
you took the high road and I saying I
you know pletely get that feel maybe
that's my ego yeah look I'm not even
saying anything I'm giving away so much
credit I'm the man that's like the
perfect amount of ego or perfectly
directed ego but cuz usually it's
eclipsed by the fact that you didn't get
your credit yeah usually yeah yeah for
sure sorry y'all want the credit gotta
work on that